so the company formerly known as
facebook is having a rough go of things
lately the social media giant is being
forced to sell one of its recent
purchases a former staffer turned
whistleblower will testify in capitol
hill again
and now the head of digital payments is
quitting so where does this leave the
company now known as meta here with more
on meta's ongoing challenges is david
kirkpatrick he is founder of teconomy
media david is the author of the
facebook effect and therefore is my
go-to on all things facebook and mark
zuckerberg david always a pleasure to
speak with you i want to get straight to
the news here which is david marcus one
of the company's top executives will be
leaving facebook turned meta at the end
of the year what do we need to know
about david marcus and why is this
significant
well thanks and love to be with you
thanks so much for having me david
marcus is one of the most impressive
people at facebook it's a major loss he
was leading a project that is extremely
important to the company most recently
creating a digital wallet for all of
facebook's
3.5 billion customer users
he is a very very well respected
throughout the industry um he's a
longtime entrepreneur he was president
of paypal before coming to facebook so
he was a very prominent hire even when
he joined in 2014
he's somebody who some of us have even
thought could theoretically be ceo of
facebook someday under some
circumstances which are unlikely but you
know he's that kind of heavy hitter
so he's that kind of heavy hitter you
mentioned that he came over to facebook
from paypal he also ran the messenger
service which was clearly a priority for
mark zuckerberg for a while
i know this is like asking you to to
speculate but how much do you think this
is tied to mark zuckerberg running the
company as his own personal playground
because he has all voting rights control
over the company and perhaps
people that he brought in to to really
professionalize
the managerial ranks may be getting fed
up with that or am i reading too much
into this and making a story out of
something that's not there
i think the realities of facebook invite
us to read a lot into things like this i
mean after all he's the
at least the third major high profile
departure this year
carolyn everson who was the head of
sales david fisher who was the head of
revenue both have also left very
recently and you know there's no
question facebook is a unique giant
company in the degree to which one
person wields all power
and
considering that he's a lot of things
that many of us question
first of all not sufficiently
remediating a range of harms which have
been proven in the facebook papers you
know endless releases of of uh
documents month or so
as well as changing the company's name
in what seems to many a very whimsical
sort of way very much based on his own
personal interests i could easily see
how a serious leader like david marcus
could say you know i'm never going to
have the influence i want here i'm going
to go somewhere else right right right
um i want to bring up what you were
saying about the digital payments effort
that uh david marcus was leading it's
called diem and of course it used to be
called libra so there are many different
names for this project it never actually
launched
why is that facebook has a thriving
marketplace i mean a lot of people buy
secondhand furniture on facebook
marketplace they use venmo to complete
the transaction they don't use any kind
of digital coin um created by facebook
why has this facebook coin digital coin
not made any traction do you think
well i think it hasn't made traction
primarily because facebook
is not trusted by
in anybody who pays close attention but
especially by government leaders around
the world who would have to either
passively accept it or regulatorily you
know approve it
that has proven much much more difficult
than they expected i don't think they
really
wanted to acknowledge even when they
first launched the libra project a
couple years ago how untrustworthy they
were felt to be
by
government officials around the world
especially in the united states but
everywhere
um
so
they've had a big problem with
credibility that's one part of it i
don't think they're going to give up
however and nobody is slightly different
than libra which was renamed dm which is
now outside of facebook's total control
and that is the currency effort uh well
novi which marcus was leading is the
wallet that would hold digital
currencies which is a separate but
closely related effort all right well
thank you for clarifying that it can get
kind of confusing but um all i know
confusing
especially when it comes from the one
you know one of the most powerful
companies in the world that's doing it
for its own personal interests right
right right and of course it hasn't
gotten off the ground either you
mentioned distrust and that's a theme
that is very prominent this week as well
because uk regulators have ordered
facebook to sell giphy which is a gift
search engine that it turns out facebook
bought in 2020 but never actually got
regulators approval for um the
regulators in the uk cited anti-trust
concerns that the purchase would track
attract more users to facebook's many
different platforms or i should say
metas many different platforms what's
significant here david is this is the
first time a major regulator has forced
a silicon valley giant to divest
a purchase that it has already completed
what's your take on this
well it is very significant as a
precedent partly because in the united
states the ftc is suing facebook and
threatening to possibly try to separate
instagram and whatsapp
which are also long ago completed uh
mergers much further back than giphy i
mean giphy was or is it jiffy i can
never get that one right i can't figure
it out
that that was a deal done in may of last
year
and completed
now the british regulatory authorities
in june
issued an order that facebook should
stop integrating the service in order to
allow them to further assess whether it
was a competitive uh harm uh whether
there was it was a marketplace uh harm
in in doing that um and then in october
uh the
the british regulators fined facebook 50
million pounds because facebook was not
cooperating with them enough in their
efforts to review this potent this the
the competitive
implications of the giffy acquisition
uh and they they said at the time it was
unprecedented that any company would
have resisted their efforts to the
degree that facebook did and in the
history of that agency the highest fine
they'd ever given to anybody in the past
was 365 000 pounds so they've already
been really angry at facebook and this
but but it could be a precedent other
governments are going to try to do
similar things yeah and that's the big
question right you mentioned instagram
is instagram next if facebook can unwind
a purchase it made last year and
regulators are looking further back what
what are the odds that a regulator
whether it's the uk one or those in the
u.s would force facebook to divest
instagram
i think the odds that they would
successfully force them to divest it is
very are very small and i think
facebook's gonna fight this thing in the
uk very hard
um they have unlimited resources as we
know 40 billion in after tax profit
roughly this year so uh i i don't think
they're going to roll over and just
divest giffy i think they will pro if
not if only because they don't want the
precedent so if they were to say yes
okay this is it's not a big deal it's a
bunch of gifts we can let somebody let
that somebody else own that but but once
they agreed to do that then it sort of
empowers the ftc
to
it legitimizes the ftc's effort to
potentially split off instagram and
whatsapp so i think you'll see them
fighting this bitterly and they would
not if instagram were ever attempted in
the same way they would fight that even
more bitterly they would do everything
in their power to fight it it would open
the floodgates essentially um the third
bit of news and this is linked in a way
to what's going on with regulators is
that francis haugen the former employee
turned whistleblower will be testifying
again before congress she's going to
speak before the house subcommittee on
section 230 which is basically the
liability shield for tech platforms that
kind of protects them because they're
just a platform they're not they don't
have editorial control over what happens
on their platform i feel like for
facebook for meta this is kind of death
by a thousand cuts every time francis
halgan gets up there and talks about
what she's seen and what she's
experienced at the company it just chips
away at the whatever goodwill facebook
has uh before regulators and before
policymakers
well she's chipping away at it in a lot
of different ways because through her
very closely coordinated pr effort she
was doling out and still i think is
doling out documents of the 10 000 that
she took with her when she left facebook
to this consortium of journalists who
are pouring over that with each week's
set of releases so they they've very
cleverly continued that and made it a
ongoing
pain for facebook very deep pain and a
lot of very disturbing revelations have
emerged from those documents uh section
230 you know one thing i will say is
that francis hogan is not deeply
respected by anybody outside of possibly
congress for her regulatory ideas you
know she is not a regular regulation
expert you know she is an inside person
who was charged with helping to
remediate harms and was frustrated that
they were not sufficiently remediated so
she left with all these documents in
protest but you know section 230 is a
complex uh issue about whether or not
speech should be controlled
whether these companies
internet platforms ought to have
responsibility for the content that is
posted by users and of course she'll say
that they ought to have more
responsibility i doubt and it will make
facebook more embarrassed no question
but i don't think it would have a huge
impact on that debate that she
personally is testifying except in that
it may further embarrass the company in
unpredictable ways yeah death by a
thousand cuts it doesn't need to
actually have the effect immediately but
over time it kind of corrodes uh what is
there david i look at the share price of
facebook and over the past one year it's
fallen or i should say it's lagged
behind the s p 500 by 10 percentage
points which is significant given how
the other technology companies the fang
socks have done fairly well which have
outperformed the s p 500 by five
percentage points all this is to say
that facebook has underperformed its
tech peers and has not done as well as
the broader market
what does the company do moving forward
i mean mark zuckerberg as you mentioned
seems to be pivoting the company uh in
the direction of his own interest the
metaverse rather than kind of paying
attention and taking stock of the
overall public opinion of his firm and
how users are responding to it how
advertisers might be changing their view
of it maybe they're not changing their
view but what what are the conversations
that are likely happening inside
facebook or do those conversations not
happen because it's mark zuckerberg's
company well the last thing you just
said is probably the closest to the
truth it's not that conversations don't
happen but
one
you know
despot
autocrat a corporate autocrat makes
those decisions and he seems
almost always very unflappable and not
concerned about public perception
especially these days he used to be more
concerned it would seem
so it's really hard to say what is going
on inside that company many of us really
wonder whether cheryl sandberg might be
feeling either very unhappy with his
decision making or and or very
marginalized by him as he's taken even
more all-powerful authority um
you know there is no question that the
stock price is is is a disappointment
but it's still gone up a lot it just
hasn't gone up as much as certain other
stocks which are extraordinary high
flyers in a uh you know historic manner
so it it's you know
google
microsoft apple east ducks have
nothing's like that's ever been seen
before it's a tough comparison facebook
is still a very valuable company whose
stock in general has performed very well
and i think for zuckerberg that's enough
it may be for some of his employees who
are compensated by stock options it is
not enough and that even could be a
problem for somebody like david marcus
we don't know right right so um final
question to david you mentioned that
facebook meta will be fighting a lot of
the issues here whether it's uk
regulators ordering it to sell giphy uh
certainly on the defensive when it comes
to david marcus departing what is
facebook's next move what is mark
zuckerberg's next move is it to still be
in reaction mode to be defensive or what
is he what is the company going to do to
stay on the offensive
they're going to try to stay on the
offensive that's their current mode they
used to be much more defensive remember
when he used to apologize for things you
know multiple times he doesn't do that
anymore he basically you know thumbs his
nose
at regulators the press
uh dissident employees and even to some
extent the public
because he believes that facebook is
basically a great service that's doing
wonderful things for its users so i
think he's going to make aggressive
moves towards metaverse functionality
whatever he thinks that is
continue really doubling down on the
hardware side of facebook which not just
with the goggles but also speakers and
other things
that are actually not doing badly
um
and i think he may just tolerate really
important people continuing to lead the
big problem he has
is that he can't recruit the best people
as easily as he used to be able to he's
basically got to pay much higher
salaries that he wants to pay yeah and
if he pays a couple million bucks he can
get any developer but they need the top
developers in the world to come there to
keep flowing there and that's a problem
they're facing and they're losing that
battle to google microsoft apple
you know even salesforce oracle etc
people don't want to work at facebook
that's possibly their biggest single
problem right now interesting in many
ways then facebook or meta is like any
other company
any other bank that's kind of struggling
to retain uh talent david thank you so
much as always david kirkpatrick uh is
founder of taconomy media and author of
the facebook effect